[Musique]
la foudre est ma prof c'est une famille
recomposée celle de christian père de
deux enfants et mario qui est enceinte
de son premier il est ingénieur elle
nutritionniste il touche de bons
salaires mais ça ne les empêche pas de
sursauter depuis quelques temps quand
ils paient leurs factures bois la viande
rouge partie yama les ports les fruits
les légumes aussi puis bon avec mon
travail de nutritionnistes faudrait
qu'une certaine part de l'alimentation
qui est des fruits et légumes donc c'est
sûr que ça paraît sur la facture c'est
certain comment ça s'est passé des
journées d'école j'ai fait le plein il
ya deux semaines puis à coûter entre 100
$
c'est la première fois que ça arrive là
sa frappe quand même ça nous empêche pas
de vivre mais c'est quelque chose qui
est un coup supplémentaire qui vient
peser dans la balance on dépense
beaucoup à l'épicerie marion et
christian surveillent leur budget de
paix les eaux noter que leurs dépenses
d'épicerie ont grimpé de 21% en octobre
comparativement à l'an dernier
leur note de chauffage au gaz a monté de
14 % c'est l'achat de carburant pour la
voiture qui a connu la hausse la plus
spectaculaire soit 60% et leurs budgets
de loisirs a aussi monté en flèche
la pandémie avec une forte demande ça
crée des problèmes de congestion sa
cause des problèmes d'augmentation des
prix de l'énergie donc ça se répercute
se répercute sur les coûts des
producteurs les coûts de livraison au
magasin où vous allez acheter vos biens
et donc évidemment c'est normal que ça
vienne affecter les prix de
l'alimentation
selon cet expert d'autres facteurs
inflationnistes s'ajoute à la pandémie
pour skier en particulier du pétrole non
seulement il ya une protéine eu de
l'offre artificielle du côté de l'opep
mais aussi une baisse de l'offre naturel
qui se fait par le peu d'investissement
secteur pétrolier tant que la demande de
pétrole elle ne suivra pas à la baisse
passée consommateur mondial en
consomment moins du pétrole je consomme
plus d'énergie alternatives et les
pressions à la hausse sur les prix vont
continuer dans ce secteur là le coût de
la vie augmente donc vers quoi est-ce
qu'on s'engage pour notre futur
financier parce que y'a personne qu'une
boule de cristal pour déterminer si si
ça va continuer à augmenter de cette
façon là on commence avec l'arrivée
prochaine d'un nouveau membre dans la
famille marion et christian avait prévu
déménager dans une maison plus grande
leur projet est maintenant en veilleuse
au lieu de déménager tout de suite on
est bon mais on va entendre vous ne rien
ménager la chambre en haut d'une des
deux filles pour mettre les deux filles
ensemble pour pouvoir faire une chambre
de bébé tout à coup
la cour
l'explosion des prix en immobilier les
prix de construction aussi atteinte et
cette décision lui aussi avait pas eu
cette explosion là on aurait
probablement déjà entamé le projet de
construction je pense que l'impact le
plus significatif pour nous de tout ça
c'est vraiment l'inconnu on voit que
tout ça se passe on voir d'une façon un
peu insidieuse l'augmentation de nos
dépenses en faire une logis du pont
champlain il ya du trafic sur le pont
champlain congestion est ce que cette
congestion là et permanente ou est-ce
que après que
la remorque est venu chercher la voiture
qui a eu un accident les conditions
s'améliorent c'est un peu la même chose
ici une fois qu'on va avoir réglé le
problème d'approvisionnement sophie de
la chaîne d'approvisionnement mondiale
au moins le problème de congestion que
probablement est une des grandes
composantes contribuer à l'augmentation
de l'inflation l'eau vive à être réglés
d'après moi d'ici la fin de l'année 2022
une étude de québec aux récentes
démontrent que le nombre de personnes
qui ont recours aux banques alimentaires
a augmenté de plus de 20% en 2021
comparativement à 2019
cela inclut des familles considérées
comme faisant partie de la classe
moyenne
ce président je vous dis qu'on regarde
actuellement des moyens pour aider les
québécois qui ont pas eu des
augmentations de salaires en conséquence
pour les aider à faire face à cette
augmentation et non du coût de la vie en
trop dans le secteur de l'épicerie puis
du logement
le mini budget à venir devrait comporter
des mesures des deux publics pour faire
face à cette inflation le couple de
gatineau a quelques idées pour le
premier ministre le go l'accès au
service de garde est primordial les
familles qui ont deux salaires ne
peuvent pas nécessairement se permettre
de tomber à 1 re salaires parce qu'ils
ont peu de place pour leurs enfants en
garderie même si ça veut dire de ramener
une certaine
subvention additionnelle pour les gens
comme ça la plus aisée moi c'est
personnellement ça me dérangerait pas de
payer un petit peu plus que ça fait de
peut-être réfléchir à la l'option
d'avoir un programme de repos dans les
écoles où un programme de collation dans
les écoles peut-être pour donner un
répit financier aux pas rares dans la
chaude de la nourriture
[Musique]